hey guys today and repaying the new
Resident Evil 7 demo sorry this took me
so long to do for you but I've been
really really ill but now I'm better so
what better way to celebrate down the
getting absolutely scared for you guys
it's always worth it I want to try and
explore every crevice of this demo and
find every secret there is to find so
let's see how well we can do Resident
Evil beginning out get out of the house
okay this will be easy simple enough
let's just hope it's not very big house
hello is that my parents beautiful cool
when I saw the trailer at e3 I was like
what it just I thought
Resident Evil was more of a action game
I used to play the really old ones on
PlayStation 1 but I don't have a video
tape let's go find a video tape oh I
shall - I shall - them against the
stones alright
do they mean bash because - doesn't make
any sense but whatever dashing means to
run very fast like this that's not
really running you pay a bit piano oh
maybe not they do not approve the music
don't play the music I want to find a
fuse is missing hmm I want to find
I think I heard footsteps out there no I
don't want to open the door I want to
find a videotape oh look bloody scissors
and stuff I want to get as much out of
the stammer as I possibly can but I
don't think the videotapes here okay
right let's go we're missing a few so
I'm guessing we come back in here I soon
anyway hello okay we're fine
this way hmm no the obvious way where
the light is but let's have a look down
here anyway right
oh look it's my hand hmm me me okay oh
it's locked
okay I hate that in games where you can
see mirrors but it doesn't allow you to
see Oh creepy hi can I have one but if
you get the one of these dolls and you
get a hair from someone that you don't
like you can stab it
voodoo doll that's a miss cop I think
you're what's the name you do doll hmm I
don't like that stairs but there's
something sparkling up there but my
objective is to leave the house so I'm
gonna way was that locked door the front
door of the house I bet you it was why
don't we just smash a window and get out
that way because that would be no fun
right
okay oh shut up now it's open the fridge
mmm I don't think I'll be having any of
that for dinner spaghetti though can't
go wrong with spaghetti
he's got what's that QG masu the 10 pack
anything in the microwave what is that
oh it's a crow okay
someone microwaved a crow they got very
hungry that's not looking here there's a
small keyhole okay let's find the key
not there mmm-hmm there's a lot of
banging going on here right let's carry
on there's a lot of lot things should I
have gone upstairs first or is down here
okay this is weird
is this supposed to look like that I
don't think I don't know doesn't look
very lovely lady she like upstairs it's
just gonna be lots of mm I don't like
mmm mmm I don't like that it only opens
the door a tiny bit I don't like that
I don't like that
oh thanks what the hell what the hell oh
my god where did you even come from
where did you come from
so creepy
what's this it's all forgotten change
well well that's good because I have
some chains in Econ but let's go out
okay oh this is so creepy
all right they have this just in the
house okay I want to find a videotape
still I really want to use ah here we go
yes derelicts house put each Matt
favorite I love abandoned buildings oh
wait this is the derelict house okay but
this one's creepy
it's got dead animals in it I don't like
this one
I'm still not gonna go upstairs I mean
no should I ah okay let's go
why have you got bag of your head why
why would you put that on your wall okay
whatever let's just go just at it
no this isn't mmm I hate mannequins ah
stairs
what's shake what what if they even do
okay
oh okay so I've got to sell out the fuse
and then I can press the button for the
stairs got this in the demo Hey
were they just facing that way were they
just facing that way oh god yes
see in the demo she was there they
showed everything in the demo this is
not good in the demo I mean in the
trailer
whatever did I just do that let's push
her over I'm sorry I didn't mean to come
down here look at my finish how am i
walking down the stairs I'm like duh
okay okay Oh
dummy finger yay why do I want a dummy
finger what oh maybe I can use that as
like a little key or something you know
to pick a lock all right you can stay
there that's what was locked all that
thing in there
now I'm get I'm gonna go pick the lock
can I go pick the lock with that part of
a dummy's hand can there not pick it no
fine I don't know why I've got a dummies
finger then why do I have a dubbing
finger how are you to go find out what
this weird grumbling man wants
hey TVs reaps me right out can I close
that door behind me
alright let's use this haunted house
rehearsal so they were faking that it
was haunted why I only work with
professionals
speaking of which make sure the sound is
right this time I don't want to repeat
of Emeril oh that was two [ __ ] years
ago
I don't do ATR this new guy can I move
around oh I can I'm filming change we do
a walk through the inside behind the
camera
Jenna the intro just like we always just
try to say the show's name this time
okay Oh for the shoulder shot to her
Gators another worthless [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
happy
what's that on the floor what is it oh
so bag of them alright I thought it's a
doll
yeah but rolling oh you're such a man I
got that on camera don't worry buddy
so why are we in hell this time this is
the same house [ __ ] me
how was it anchor you know we can
subpoena not anchor what say nothing
what's the story Andre abandoned
farmhouse missing family foul play
suspected the usual how long do you say
this place has been abandoned three
years auntie get a shot of this let's
make a great cut away
what hillbilly Jonah's family go missing
not hillbillies the baker's jack and
Marguerite Baker and they were quiet not
backwards three years ago and there's
still food enjoy Lucas what are you
doing why would you wear good shoes into
an abandoned place where is our buddy
John what do you think he's gone
please go I can't move okay Andre Andre
no idea maybe upstairs the mannequins
are gone no where are you
I I left you where'd you go oh oh oh I'm
an idiot why did I leave him otherwise
okay there's no voodoo dolls yep should
we look in
Andre where the [ __ ] is he
Audrey well you man says secret passage
in here or something ooh a fireplace I
don't think I saw that before
did it help all right new deal we find
Andre and we go I mean [ __ ] this show
okay move your butt I want to go through
don't leave me a man
you first need a nice hero shot of meat
coming down the ladder yeah whatever you
say
you first hey it's a friend hey
Oh God he fell on us as well that's
disgusting
hey lavage oh look someone left this
here I shall - you against the stones I
still think that he means bash
should we let the ghosty know that they
are using grammar wrong - maybe I'm
using it wrong I thought - meant to run
whatever feels like I'm run against the
thingy right let's find the secret all
the secrets
okay
Who am I like why am I here am i that
camera person no because I don't have a
camera
maybe I'm the man no because then I
would have known what was on that tape
anyway yeah whatever
doesn't matter back door key hey donuts
go down here yes you probably shouldn't
should I should I go down I feel like I
shouldn't but I want to but I feel like
I shouldn't I feel like I'll die [ __ ]
that's it Oh
what you can't go down there oh maybe if
we can just have a peek see nothing
happens what am I so creepy if if you
look down at the right angle there was
just someone staring at you you're like
in PT when you looked up at the stairs
and there was the woman and she's just
staring at you you're are there freaking
me out
anyway that game's not in development
but it's okay because we got a new one
coming so it's alright
no sorry I thought I thought my
flashlight was gonna go off don't know
don't know where did you even come from
stop this I dislike you
they're upset okay don't even don't even
look don't even that's not okay it's
fine
be polite
let's close this stuff sorry I wasn't
here it's like I was never here okay
what the bloody hell how did you get
here
I know what took you downstairs but it's
not taking here
okay this keep on walking because the
key
hey everybody never opened the little
drawer what the bloody hell might even
come from why were you hiding wait no
it's it can't be here because then he
said I need to open the drawer
no that cap yet I had a drawers are open
didn't I
I'm gonna starting again now hmm yes I
can't oh yeah I can it's doing now see
what's there if I go early hey I'm here
early and I have a freaking fuse to the
stairs I forgot I needed that too so
someone must have come in here at some
point and taken the fuse cuz that
definitely wasn't there before
I would remember so that's carry him did
is it there fabulous let's go upstairs I
thought I just heard talking and it
creeped me out
I don't forget it oh they do move I knew
they did right oh my yeah right past the
button stairs says to what is it that
way okay Oh Li did the Attic
the real attic there's a phone up here
what hello this is where he lives
his shoes yeah hello
I know who you are
morning you have the power to choose a
pee on them with that choice may not be
what you expect
jeez whoa let's try and burn someone
that obviously works cool nine nine nine
nine one one nope engaged
hmm what's this oh yeah are they
watching us from that helicopter the
umbrella corporation oh go away I hate
you mannequins what the bloody hell why
did he find me where did he even come
from hey German army noises we're gonna
get back upstairs we're gonna find all
the secrets I love that there's can like
multiple different endings I guess I
thought it was just gonna be a demo
that's the same pretty much however you
play it so I'm glad that it's not like
that
I'm still gonna get the little the
little doll finger because I have no
idea what it's useful dummy finger
that's the one
we're not going in here we're gonna get
straight ahead you can draw the phone
that the man what ah it's a dead end
guys is the dead end what do i do I want
to find the room in the end you know
what the room in the end where he gets
killed
I'm guessing it's that one because it's
all barricades up I've got other things
to figure out in this game before I die
where did he even come from so if I
answer this I don't think I die
straightaway
maybe just cuz I was lingering you have
the power to choose I know
okay
how does she know who I am
where does he even come from I have to
get into that drawer that's it's gotta
be number ending so is that the lockpick
oh my mistake him yeah I know it doesn't
work I can't use it so I have no idea
what that's for
oh maybe it's the stop with the weird
noises stop it
turn off the tap maybe I put it on the
little doll because there is a little
doll that like falls down here
what was in here again Oh God
stop it you weirdo yeah see part of a
dummy's hand but I've got the dummy
right here and I can't do anything with
this it's a weird doll oh it's very
creepy
okay so video stop
weird it I don't know if it's a man
gnarling or or if it's a dog whatever oh
wait can I do different things when I'm
recording hey I am professional shut up
wishes creepy things like people staring
up some places we don't expect them to
be that's what I love about how are you
he's rude I didn't realize how Rudy was
the first time around
Oh lockpick wait me now that I've picked
it up so I mean that I can't pick it up
outside of video land oh well okay and
then what's in here oh okay so now I
have to go through the whole thing to
look in here when I'm not in the video I
think well I think it's open now okay
okay
oops I really it where should we go
Jun Jie Jie hacking slashing I'm good
I'm gonna break the ax before I even get
to the guy by now let's go upstairs guys
cuz I know I know you wanna do I get the
front door key no I don't think I do I
think I just go up here let's ignore the
phone call if you pick it up we are dead
meat
what no come on
well nice mystery the sex I thought this
ax would easily break through all this
wood there's that's so annoying don't
really don't really want to pick up that
phone because I'm pretty sure he'll come
and get me
there's nothing in that crate his his
shoes are made of steel yeah what is
this why can't you cut through wood what
does the axe even for but why would they
give me an axe if it's got no use not
impressed the baby's gone guys
baby has left the building
I can't try it oh maybe I can chop up
some meat no good it doesn't look very
appetizing anyway I don't really want it
I thought that was gonna be like loads
of different secret endings or something
was I wrong die oh did I look too much
into the game that's very disappointing
if that is the case because why why give
me a [ __ ] dummy finger and then that
I know it's only demo but I don't care I
want to see a zombie at least one zombie
it's a Resident Evil demo let me see if
Tommy I see the guy who speaks to me
don't even hurt any of these dummies I
know you know my parents whoa
oh that was different from cool that was
different phone call that was different
phone call memory tell the truth don't
just mislead you that was a different
phone call okay
I'm slightly happy yeah at least the
phone calls different the endings to
exactly same way and we didn't even get
to see that room I think that room was
the room that was boarded up to be
honest thanks for watching this
playthrough of the Resident Evil demo I
don't really know what to think about it
to be honest I'm just a bit confused
because I don't understand why they
would give me an axe and prompt me to
attack when there is nothing to attack I
can't kill the guy
I can't where I can break the boxes but
there's nothing in the boxes I can't
break down any doors I just I just don't
know what to do and why the bloody hell
is there a dummy finger randomly in the
drawer I don't know I just feel like I
was made to do a lot of things leading
up to finding the axe but then once you
get the axe there's nothing to do with
it it doesn't make sense there must be
something to do with the axe please if
you know anything that I missed out let
me know in the comments below I need to
know so I'll be more than happy to do
another playthrough if I've missed an
amazing ending or something just let me
know let's work this out together
also oh no what you think what do you
think of this wasn't evil demo it's very
different to how we remember Resident
Evil being AI is that a good thing is
that a bad thing let's see what you guys
think let's start a conversation in the
comments give this a thumbs up if you
enjoyed and have a lovely dairy thing
bye ah ah how many matches have I got
wait how do I do that
leave me alone
I never did anything to you
apart from intruder Woods but I'm just
trying to help
I should have bought candy